اعداد الهزات الارتداديه تقريبا التي تلت
الزلزالت تتجاوز الثلاثين هزه نتحدث عن 32
او 32 هزه ارتداديه شهدتها هذه الولايات
العاشره بعد الزلزال الرئيسي الذي ضرب
كهرمان من مرعش وبقوه 7.4 طبعا وزير
الداخليه التركي قبل قليل سليمان عن اطلاق
الانذار من المستوى الرابع وهذا يعني طلب
مساعده دوليه عاجله من لتركيا بالتالي هذا
ينبئ بشكل او باخر محمد عن ان نحن امام
كارثه وعدد ربما عدد ضحايا تكون كبيره جدا
وايضا الدمار يكون كبير جدا هذا الان
تصليح دوالي كهرمان مرعش يتحدث انه لا
يستطيع حتى الان ان يعطي احصائيه رسميه عن
اعداد الضحايا وكما ذكرت يعني الاعلان
السلطات التركيه
درجه درجه الانذار او من المرتبه
الرابعه هذا ينبغي ان حجم الكارثه كبير
نتحدث عن عشر ولايات تضررت
بزلزال شدته 7.4 هذا اكبر زلزال ربما حتى
الان بحسب ما اعلم منذ زلزال الشهير الذي
ضرب اسطنبول في عام 1999 والذي راح ضحيته
اكثر من 17 الف قتيل واضحيه خلال هذه خلال
ذاك الزلزال نتحدث تقريبا عن حاله مشابهه
لكن هذه المره
تضرب عشره ولايات تركيه ولذلك ربما نتحدث
عن اعداد اصابات كبيره وايضا على ضحايا
كبيره الموضوع لم يتوقف هنا ايضا
نتحدث عن اعداد ضحايا العشرات في شمال
سوريا تحديدا في المناطق ما بين
الدانه في ريف ادلب الشمالي وايضا عفرين
ريف حلب الشمالي هذه المناطق التي تقع في
تحت السيطره المعارضه هناك العشرات ممن ما
زالوا تحت الانقاض تحت الانقاض وفرق
الدفاع المدني معتزاز تحاول الوصول اليهم
ايضا
الزلزال في العاصمه السوريه دمشق سمع او
حتى السكان هناك الزلزال وهناك ضحايا في
حلب وايضا في الساحل السوري كل هذه
الانبا ما زالت اوليه هنا اعداد ضحايا
مرشحه للارتفاع الاسيه في شمال سوريا وفي
جنوب تركيا